[Musique]
je m'appelle qui mélangerait et je suis
un fermier du fleuve voyais à toto je
suis installé ici depuis à peu près 20
ans
pour les cowboys du fleuve voyais à toto
la conquête de l'ouest a débuté sur ses
terres blotti entre les alpes et néo
zélandaises et la mer de tasman
sur les traces des premiers colons kim a
choisi de s'installer ici
les caprices du fleuve
la violence des précipitations
font de cette région l'une des plus
hostiles et isolée de nouvelle zélande
l'histoire de kim a pour décor cette
côte mythique
on utilise beaucoup le bateau dans notre
région ils nous aident à faire traverser
nos bêtes
on élève des vaches de race hereford
[Musique]
je travaille en famille on élève nos
bêtes de façon très écologique
[Musique]
ces vaches ont fait la réputation des
fermiers de la côte ouest
elles sont considérées aujourd'hui comme
les plus belles de nouvelle zélande
[Musique]
sans novembre et c'est le printemps dans
l'hémisphère sud comme chaque année en
cette période le fleuve wyatt auto
déborde encore gorgés des pluies
abondantes de l'hiver
le printemps c'est aussi le début de la
saison pour kim et sa famille ils
rassemblent leurs troupeaux à la mode
locale à cheval et en bateau quand l
approche de la rivière on le dirige avec
le bateau ça les encourage à traverser
et vous ne pourriez pas travailler sans
les anciens faisaient sens mais beaucoup
de gens se noyer avec leurs veaux
il a fallu en sauver un paquet d'un
mètre vaches
là on essaie de faire traverser les mers
et leurs petits
on fait ça pour les emmener dans un
enclos de l'autre côté à la ferme on
doit les marques et on va leur offrir de
jolies boucles d'oreilles pour les fers
belges
ont l'air de ne pas vouloir y aller on
va voir ce qu'on peut faire
elle repart vers le bouge c'est pas
idéal
vas-y vas-y vas-y
[Musique]
ja il est cédé à terre j'ai besoin d'un
truc différent là pour les effrayer
[Musique]
doucement les chiens
mais qu'à cocher arythmique
ça suffit
a bougé
convaincre les bêtes de quitter leur
territoire c'est du sport
o'leary fait attention aux petits là le
laissera partir revenir vers mener ok
c'est bon essayer de traverser comme ça
deux fois par an qui me prépare un grand
événement la foire au bétail de la ville
deux astres en une semaine la famille
doit capturer une quarantaine de bêtes
pour cette vente
kim est né à wanaka dans une ferme à des
centaines de kilomètres du fleuve voyait
totaux
son père cultivait de la lavande
lui ne rêvait que d'une chose mettre ses
pas dans ceux des pionniers de la côte
ouest
[Musique]
alors il y a 20 ans il s'est offert son
ranch
qui m'y a élevé ses enfants
est vite aujourd'hui son rêve de cow boy
[Musique]
demande pourquoi on vit ici jette un
oeil à ça
j'ai mes enfants on travaille ensemble
on fait du bon boulot ici
et papa que tu vois les vaches derrière
toi
non je ne pense pas non elles sont
toutes devant la
la grande vente au détail de as tu es
dans quelques jours et qui m'a bien
l'intention d'y exposer ses plus beaux
spécimens
qu'est ce qu'elles ont de si spécial
veaux vaches c'est la région c'est le
mode d'élevage j'imagine
cet hymne est ici avec toute la pluie
condat elles sont obligés d'apprendre à
nager très vite
reparler d'une sélection naturelle à la
darwin beaucoup de gens n'y croient pas
mais dans leur cas c'est probablement
vrai
[Musique]
seuls les plus forts survivent
voilà donc le secret des cowboys de la
terre de l'ouest et de leur cheptel
d'exception
[Musique]
la famille doit maintenant séparés pour
la vente les maires de leurs petits
mais même prisonnière de l'enclos les
vaches de la côte conserve intacts leurs
instincts sauvages
les maires ne veulent pas lâcher leurs
mots elles sont nerveuses
il est rappelé par la queue attention
attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'on en a 17
quelle pagaille
c'est pas grave laisse les génisses il
faudra les séparer de toute façon
on va lui faire belle pour la vente
c'est vraiment pour ça ouais parce que
moi je suis déjà magnifique mais ce pas
mais non il plaisante c'est une puce
électronique
ça permettra de savoir à qui
appartiennent les belles heures de la
boîte
allez venez par là
ça ne leur fait pas mal
dans la région il aime les volets plus
ça coûte tellement cher devenir acheté
jusqu'ici que quand ils se déplacent ils
ne veulent que du très bon ces petits
laval 500 dollars mais si la vente était
dans un mois il serait plus gros et je
pourrais en tirer 800
alors les cinq sens à la vie maintenant
où j'attends
vous êtes un peu anxieux
papa tu peux fermer la barrière s'il te
plaît bilan de la première journée 17
vos marques est prêt pour la vente
le printemps c'est aussi ça sur la côte
ouest
les chevaux sont restés à la ferme ce
matin
malgré la pluie kim s'est levé aux
aurores la vente et dans quelques jours
il a encore besoin d'une vingtaine de
bêtes aller dof ça roule
qu'est ce que tu veux
je voulais savoir si tu pouvais m'en
mais pour jeter un oeil clos dans la
vallée j'ai dû bêta il rassemblait tu
serais mieux à la maison parce autant je
sais que c'est pas terrible mais
j'espère qu'on peut y aller quand même
bon écoute le plein effet tu m'aides a
poussé aller en plus ensemble
les fermiers de la région ne savent pas
vraiment le nombre de terres qu'il
possède
par malice ou par orgueil ils vous
répondent un peu par ci un peu par là la
vérité c'est que les vaches de qui m'ont
des milliers d'hectares à leur
disposition
on va essayer de localiser les bêtes qui
vivent quelque part dans le coin
sans hélicoptères on pourrait venir avec
les chevaux et les chiens
mais on ne sait pas exactement où elles
sont parce que c'est tellement vaste
avec toute cette forêt
ses vaches n'ont vu personne depuis
combien de temps où les vaches ça doit
faire un an les veaux et n'ont jamais vu
personne
il y à du bétail qui courent ici depuis
les années 70 on susurre
est alors comment ça se passe quand vous
les approchez elle s'enfuit quand on
arrive on ne peut pas dire qu'elle nous
apprécient vraiment
quand tu ne les trouve pas comme
maintenant on cherche des traces
on cherche des empreintes ou de la
mousse
mais là je ne vois rien
on va essayer de repasser de l'autre
côté
[Musique]
la
wii y en a là bas
il y à un taureau sauvage
de petits 3 12 13 il y en a à peu près
douze ou treize ici
on est passé trois fois sans voir aucun
signe un
magnifique elles sont bannis change en
pleine santé
regarde la maman elle dit à son petit
pas par là tu prends le mauvais chemin
c'est un plaisir immense motivé trouve
c'est un sentiment super ça a l'air
d'être un jeu pour vous un jeu wii un
jeu où elles gagnent souvent croyez-moi
[Musique]
le troupeau a gagné la partie pour un
temps au moins le lendemain si la météo
s'améliore c'est à cheval qu'il viendra
leur assemblée
mais sur le chemin du retour les
éléments vont lui mener la vie dure les
nouvelles de la ferme ne sont pas bonnes
la pluie n'a pas cessé de tomber
l'homme connaît bien son fleuve et il
est inquiet
dans la vallée le voyais à toto a tout
envahi
chaque année le fleuve qui traverse la
propriété fait des ravages
et cette fois encore le ranch de la
famille n'est pas épargné
qui nous doit faire vite
il a perdu l'an dernier tout un troupeau
emporté par le courant
les vaches qu'il a soigneusement choisi
ces derniers jours pour la vente prise
de panique s'échappe
[Musique]
le fermier au risque de voir le travail
d'une année anéanti doit leur couper la
route et les mettre en sécurité avant
qu'elle n'atteigne le fleuve
les champs a été submergé par la marée
le problème c'est que le bétail étaient
pris entre le niveau de la mer et le
fleuve qui est trop
comme tu peux voir c'est bien monté on
les a mis dans l'enclos des chevaux ça
monte encore mais c'est plus sûr c'est
la première fois depuis très longtemps
ça déborde comme ça normalement lorsque
la mer descend elle régule le niveau du
fleuve mais c'était trop gros avec toute
cette pluie vraiment trop gros une
énorme cru
le troupeau et sauver la vente de as tu
es dans 48 heures
mais il manque toujours à l'éleveur
quelques vaches impossible de passer par
le fleuve alors kim va abattre sa
dernière carte
on est prêt les gars
qui m'a appelé en renfort ses voisins
greg le pilote et fils le tireur d'élite
les deux hommes sont spécialisés dans la
capture du bétail
le fermier a passé un marché avec eux et
c'est ainsi que ça fonctionne dans la
région
sur les vaches capturés l'une d'entre
elle reviendra aux chasseurs
voilà il y en a des jeunes là
je veux faire demi tour tu veux que le
positionne sur le côté ou derrière
regardez les arrive c'est les deux
petites là
oui on shoppe la cultive d'abord
c'est bon c'est la bonne
[Musique]
il
bon je vais descendre un peu tu vas
pouvoir sauter et kim
il
[Musique]
une fois le veau immobilisé il faut
aller vite
leur but traumatisé le moins possible
l'animal
là on va s'accrocher à l'hélico et ils
vont le ramener jusqu'à la fin
[Applaudissements]
le poids de la vache ne permet pas à
l'hélicoptère d'embarquer kim
tu vois on lui attacher les pattes
et c'est parti
la technique c'est de bien lui prendre
les cornes pour que sa position ne soit
pas trop inconfortable
et là ça va pour elle
on sera bientôt là bas on va la détacher
et la relâcher dans l'emploi
le truc le plus important pour nous
c'est d'être le plus gentil possible
avec le bétail et de ne blesser ni les
verts ni les hommes
le vol ne dure que quelques minutes le
jeune veau et déposés dans son enclos
tout en douceur
[Musique]
les trois chasseurs vont ainsi renouvelé
l'opération une dizaine de fois dans la
journée
[Musique]
darracq
voix
[Musique]
elle n'a pas l'air très contente quand
même
c'est pas trop mal elle veut juste
retrouver son troupeau elle était
heureuse maintenant
[Musique]
fait merveille
après une semaine de batailles acharnées
contre le wyatt auto le cow boy du
fleuve semble enfin avoir réuni son
troupeau
36 jeunes veaux qu'il conduira après
demain à la grande vente de vastes
dimanche à la ferme et le soleil semble
enfin de la partie
kim a décidé de s'offrir une journée de
répit dans un de ces endroits préférés
sur la côte
à quelques kilomètres à peine du ranch
jackson b le bout du monde
[Musique]
c'est de ce petit village niché dans la
baie qu'a débuté la conquête de la terre
de l'ouest
les premiers colons ils avaient établi
leur camp de base
jackson bêtes aujourd'hui réputée pour
ses pêcheurs de langoustes
kim est très attaché à ce dieu et à son
histoire
[Musique]
non
c'est un endroit magnifique
bien souvent ici pour déjeuner ou juste
pour voir quelque chose de différent
notre ferme est très belle mais la mer
est extraordinaire
cette belle n'a pas changé depuis un
siècle
les premiers colons ont choisi cette
baisse car c'était le seul endroit où
ils pouvaient accoster regarde c'est
notre ferme de l'autre côté droit devant
d'en avaler
les navires de charge et le bêta ici ils
les attachaient les faisait passer par
dessus bord et les jeter à l'eau
il les pousse et ensuite dans les vagues
jusqu'à la berge
c'est comme ça qu'on apportait les
animaux de l'étranger
ensuite il y avait encore trois ou
quatre jours à cheval avant de les
vendre dans les fermes
c'était pâques n'est pas si lointaine
quand on vous voit dans votre ferme
on élève nos bêtes comme à l'époque avec
nos chevaux et des chiens concept de nos
jackpot aujourd'hui mais nos gestes sont
restés les mêmes c'est quand même plus
facile c'était vraiment beaucoup plus
dur à l'époque
[Musique]
le grand jour
700 dollars et elles sont avant qui pour
700 on est à 6 ans 81 86 ans 81 80 c'est
du très beau bétail 975 et on arrête
l'enchère 975 vendu
la irin c'est une vente en complet
cravate pour ce qui se fait de mieux sur
la côte ouest les jeunes jouent du
fleuve wyatt auto tous les éleveurs de
la région se donne ainsi rendez-vous
deux fois dans la saison
1150 vendu
c'était du beau bétail st je comprends
pas pourquoi elles n'ont pas mieux
vendus ou qui mettent un peu inquiète un
peu tendu cette vente est
l'aboutissement d'une année de dur
labeur
1150 1150 pas plus
je note toutes les enchères à 1260 ça me
permettra de comparer quand ce sera mon
tour c'était 1260 la dernière
son tour c'est le lot 48 et c'est
maintenant
90 90 mettez le prix est embarqué dans
votre coffre son patient kim
505 105-110 attend 10 à 510 est ce qu'on
vend kim est ce qu'elles paraissent à
110 110 vendus
j'avais dit que je ne vendrais pas entre
550 mais j'ai craqué
[Musique]
ça fait de la place pour les veaux de
l'année prochaine en automne il ya une
autre aventure je me rattraperai
c'est le résultat d'une année de travail
et ça n'est pas un résultat folichon je
suppose non
mais bon on ne fait pas vraiment ça pour
l'argent c'est plutôt un style de vie
c'est très excitant on monte à cheval on
pilote des bateaux on traque les vaches
avec nos chiens c'est cool on s'amuse
c'est plutôt unis ça n'arrive
probablement nulle part ailleurs au
monde
unique grandiose hostile et généreuse la
terre de l'ouest et tout ça à la fois
à l'image de son fleuve l'indomptable
wyatt auto
[Musique]